What do you love?
What do you fear?
What would you like to change in the world?
My name's Kevin Macdonald and I'm a film director...
...and I'd like to make a film with you.
On July 25th, take your camera, film your day and tell your story.
It's called Life in a Day 2020 and it's a crowd-sourced documentary.
A portrait of the world on a single day.
Everybody and anybody is relevant to this film...
...no matter what your experience is.
This is actually a sequel to a film we made 10 years ago.
July 24th, 2010.
The first time was a statement of where we were then...
...and this will be a statement of where we are now.
You don't need me to tell you that this has been an extraordinary year.
There are so many huge important things going on in the world...
...and that might be reflected in what you film.
But what's going to be of interest to you might be something more intimate,...
...something more personal.
Today we're going to video Sacha's first ever shave.
What's important to you in your life, your specific life.
What we don't want is the glossy, perfect social media version of you.
We want authenticity, we want reality.
My advice is just do it.
The film will then be shown at Sundance Film Festival...
...and will be available for everyone to see on YouTube.
This film is going to be something we hope you'll look back on...
...and say "Oh, that's what it was like in 2020."